[Music]
ten years before the Spaniards first
came here a bad omen appeared in the sky
it was like a flaming ear of corn
or a fiery signal or the blaze of
daybreak it seemed to bleed fire drop by
drop like a wound in the sky it was wide
at the base and narrow of the peak and
it shone in the very heart of the
heavens
when it first appeared there was great
outcry and confusion the people clapped
their hands against their mouths they
were amazed and frightened and asked
themselves what it could mean the second
bad omen the temple of Huitzilopochtli
burst into flames it is thought that no
one set it afire that had burned down of
its own accord
the third bad omen a temple was damaged
by a lightning bolt this was the temple
absurd acutally which was built of straw
it was raining that day but it was only
a light rain who were a drizzle and no
thunder was heard the fourth bad omen
fire streamed through the sky while the
Sun was still shining the fifth bad omen
the wind lashed the water until it
boiled it was if it were boiling with
rage as if it was shattering itself in
its frenzy it began from far off rose
high in the air and dashed against the
walls of the houses the flooded houses
collapsed into the water this was in the
lake that is next to us the sixth bad
omen the people heard a weeping woman
night after night she passed by in the
middle of the night wailing and crying
out in a loud voice my children we must
flee away from this city at other times
she cried my children where shall I take
you the seventh wonder was this the men
whose work is in the lake of Mexico
trapped a dark feathered bird resembling
a crane and took it to Mata kazuma so
that you might see it he was in the
palace of the black Hall the Sun was
already in the West
the bird was so unique and marvelous
that no one could exaggerate its
strangeness or describe it well around
diadem was set in its head in the form
of a clear and transparent mirror in
which could be seen the heavens when
mater Kazuma saw this he was filled with
dread and Wonder for he believed it was
a bad omen to see the stars of heavens
in the diadem of that bird when mater
Kazuma looked into the mirror for a
second time he saw a host of people all
armed like warriors coming forward in
well-ordered ranks they skirmished and
fought with each other and they were
accompanied by strange deer and other
creatures the eighth wonder and sign
that appeared in Mexico the natives saw
two men merged into one body and others
who had two heads but only one body they
were brought to the palace of the black
Hall to be shown to the great Montezuma
but they vanished as soon as he had seen
them to the natives these marvels all go
to their death and ruin signifying that
the end of the world was coming and that
other people's would be created to
inhabit the earth
a few days later a common man came to
the city from mikta Hudler no one had
sent him none of the officials he came
of his own accord he went directly to
the palace of mater Kazuma and said to
him our Lord and King forgive my
boldness when I went to the shores of
the Great Sea there was a mountain range
or small mountain floating in the midst
of the water and moving here and there
without touching the shore my lord we
have never seen the like of this
although we guard the coast and are
always on watch
mater Kazuma thanked him and said you
may rest now the man who brought this
news had no ears for they had been cut
off and no toes who they had also been
cut off then he called for a priest and
appointed him to his grand emissary he
said to him go to quirt Laxton and tell
the official in charge of the village
that it is true
strange things have appeared on the
Great Sea tell him to investigate these
things himself so as to learn what they
may signify tell them to do this as
quickly as he can and take the
Ambassador with you when they arrived in
qua text on the invoice spoke with the
officials in charge there a man named
Binet oh he listened to them with great
attention and then said my Lords rest
here with me and send your attendants
out to the shore the attendants went out
and came back in great haste to report
that it was true they had seen two
towers or small mountains floating on
the waves of the sea
the grand emissary said to pinnacle I
wish to see these things in person in
order to learn what they are
I must testify to our Lord as an
eyewitness therefore he went out to the
shore and they saw what was floating
there beyond the edge of the water
[Music]
they also saw that seven or eight of the
strangers had left it in a small boat
and were fishing with hooks and lines
they climbed up into a broad limb tree
from there they saw how the strangers
were catching fish and how when they
were done they returned to the ship in
their small boat they climbed down from
the tree and went back to the village
where they took hasty leave of binnacle
they returned as swiftly as possible to
the great city of Tanaka clan to report
tamati Kazuma what they had observed
when they reached the city they went
directly to the king's palace and spoke
to him with all due reverence and
humility how Lord and King it is true
that strange people have come to the
shores of the Great Sea they were
fishing from a small boat some with rods
and others with a net they fished until
late and then they went back to their
two great towers and climbed up into
them there are about 15 of these people
some with blue jackets others with red
others with black or green still others
with jackets of a soiled color very ugly
there are also a few without jackets on
their heads they wore red handkerchiefs
or bonnets of a fine scarlet colour and
some wore large round hats which must
have been sun shades they have very
light skin much lighter than ours they
all have long beards and their hair
comes only to their ears what a Kazuma
was downcast when he heard this report
and did not speak a word
mata Kazuma then gave orders to his
officials he said to them give out this
order a watch is to be kept along all
the shores the officials left at once
and gave orders for the watch to be kept
mata Kazuma now called his chiefs
together he told them the news that had
been brought to him and showed them the
objects he had ordered made
he said the whole treasure must be
guarded well if anything is lost your
houses will be destroyed and your
children killed even those who are still
in the womb the year thirteen rabbit now
approached its end and when it was about
to end
they appeared the report of their coming
was brought to Mata Kazuma who
immediately sent out messages It was as
if he thought the new arrival was our
Prince Quetzalcoatl this is what he felt
in his heart he has appeared he has come
back he will come here to the place of
his throne and canopy for that is what
he promised when he departed Mata Kazuma
sent five messengers to greet the
strangers and to bring them gifts he
said to them come forward my Jaguar
knights come forward it is said that our
Lord has returned to this land go to
meet him go to hear him listen well to
what he tells you he is what you are to
bring to our Lord this is the treasure
of Quetzalcoatl due reverence to our
Lord the God say to him your deputy
mater Kazuma has sent us to you here are
the presents with which he welcomes you
home to Mexico when they arrived at the
shore of the sea they were taken in
canoes to Sakhalin KO they placed the
baskets in the same canoes in which they
rode in order to keep them under their
personal vigilance from sickle anko they
followed the coast until they sighted
the ships of the strangers
when they came up to the ships the
strangers asked them who are you where
are you from we have come from the city
of Mexico the stranger said you may have
come from there who you may not have
perhaps you are only inventing it
perhaps you are mocking us but their
hearts were convinced they were
satisfied in their hearts they lowered a
hook from the bow of the ship another
ladder and the messengers came aboard
one by one they did reverence to Cortes
by touching the ground before him with
their lips they said to him if the god
will deign to hear us
your deputy mater Kazuma has sent us to
render you homage he has the city of
Mexico in his care he says the God is
weary
then they arrayed the captain in the
finery they had brought him as presents
with great care they fastened the
turquoise mask in place the mask of the
God with its cross band of quetzel
feathers a golden earring hung down on
either side of this mask they dressed
him in the decorated vest and the collar
woven in the potato style a collar with
a disc of gold in the center next they
fastened the mirror to his hips dressed
him in the cloak known as the ringing
Bell andin don't his feet with the
Greaves used by the hasta cuss in his
hand
they placed the shield with its fringe
and pendant of quetzel feathers its
ornaments of gold and mother-of-pearl
finally they set before him the pair of
black sandals the captain asked them and
is this all is this your gift of welcome
is this how you greet people they
replied this is all Lord this is what we
have brought you
then the captain gave orders and the
messengers were chained by the feet and
neck when this had been done the great
cannon was fired off the messengers lost
their senses and fainted away they fell
down side by side and lay where they had
fallen but the Spaniards quickly revived
them they lifted them up gave them wine
to drink and then offered them some food
the captain said to them I have heard
that the Mexicans are very great
warriors very brave and terrible if a
Mexican is fighting alone he knows how
to retreat
turn back rush forwards and conquer even
if his opponents are ten or even twenty
but my heart is not convinced I want to
see it for myself I want to find out if
you are truly that strong and brave then
he gave them swords spears and leather
shields he said it will take place very
early at daybreak we are going to fight
each other in pairs and in this way we
will learn the truth we will see who
falls to the ground they said to the
captain our lord we were not sent here
for this by your deputy Mata kazuma we
have come on an exclusive mission to
offer you rest and repose and to bring
you presents if we were to do this it
might anger Mata kazuma and he would
surely put us to death the captain
replied no it must take place I want to
see for myself because even in Castile
they say you are famous as brave
warriors therefore eat an early meal I
will eat too good cheer with these words
he sent them away from the ship they
were scarcely into their canoes when
they began to paddle furiously some of
them even paddled with their hands so
fierce was the anxiety burning in their
souls they said to each other
my captain's paddle with all your might
- faster faster nothing must happen to
us here nothing must happen
while the messengers were away mati
Kazuma could neither sleep nor eat and
no one could speak with him he thought
that everything he did was in vain and
he sighed almost every moment he was
lost in despair in the deepest gloom and
sorrow
nothing could comfort him nothing could
calm him nothing could give him any
pleasure he said what will happen to us
who will outlive it ah in other times I
was contented but now I have death in my
heart but with our Lord come here then
he gave orders to the watchman to
captives are to be painted with chalk
the messengers went to the house of the
serpent and mati Kazuma arrived the two
captives were then sacrificed before his
eyes and the messengers were sprinkled
with their blood this was done because
the messengers had completed a difficult
mission they had seen the gods their
eyes had looked on their faces they'd
even conversed with the gods when the
sacrifice was finished the messengers
reported to the king they told him how
they had made the journey and what they
had seen and what food the strangers ate
mater Kazuma was astonished and
terrified by their report and a
description of the strangest food
astonished him above all else it was
also terrified to learn how the cannon
roared how its noise resounded how it
caused one to faint and want to grow
deaf the messengers told him a thing
like a ball of stone comes out of its
entrails it comes out shooting sparks
and raining fire the smoke that comes
out with it as a pestilent odor like
that of rotten mud this odor penetrates
even to the brain and causes the
greatest discomfort if the cannon is
aimed against a mountain the mountain
splits and cracks open if it is aimed
against a tree it shatters the tree into
splinters this is a most unnatural sight
as if the tree has exploded from within
the messengers also said their trappings
and arms are all made of iron they dress
in iron and where iron casks on their
heads their swords are iron their boughs
are iron their shields are iron their
spears are iron their deer carry them on
their backs wherever they wish to go
these deer our Lord are as tall as the
roof of a house the strangest bodies are
completely covered so that only their
faces can be seen their skin is white as
if it were made of lime they have yellow
hair though some of them have black
their beards are long in yellow and
their moustaches are also yellow the
hair is curly with very fine strands as
for their food it is like human food it
is large and white and not heavy is
something like straw but with the taste
of corn stalk of the pith of corn stalk
it is a little sweet as if it were
flavoured with honey it is sweet tasting
food their dogs are enormous with flat
ears and long dangling tongues the color
of their eyes is a burning yellow their
eyes flash firing and shoot off sparks
their bellies are hollow their flanks
long and narrow
they are tireless and very powerful they
bound here in their panting with their
tongues hanging out and they are spotted
like an ocelot when Mata kazuma heard
this report he was filled with terror It
was as if his heart had fainted as if it
had shriveled it was at this time that
Mata kazuma sent out a deputation he
sent out his most gifted men his
prophets and wizards as many as he could
gather he also sent out his noblest and
bravest warriors they had to take their
provisions with them on the journeys
life hens and hens eggs and tortillas
they also took whatever the strangers
request whatever might please them mata
Kazuma also sent captives to be
sacrificed because the strangers might
wish to drink their blood the invoice
sacrificed these captives in the
presence of the strangers but when the
white men saw this done they were filled
with disgust and loathing they spat on
the ground or wiped away their tears or
close their eyes and shook their heads
and abhorrent they refused to eat the
food that was sprinkled with blood
because it weakened of it did it
sickened them as if the blood had rotted
mater Kazuma ordered the sacrifice
because he took the Spaniards to be gods
he believed in them and he worshiped
them as deities then the strangers ate
the tortillas the eggs and the hens and
fruit of every variety guavas avocados
prickly pears and the many other kinds
that grow here there was food for the
deer also read shoots and green grasses
Mota Kazuma had sent the magicians to
learn what sort of people the strangers
might be but they were also to see if
they could work some charm against them
or do them some mischief they might be
able to direct a harmful wind against
them or cause them to break out in sores
or injure them in some way or they might
be able to repeat some enchanted word
over and over that would cause them to
fall sick or die or return to their own
land the magicians carried out their
mission against the Spaniards but they
failed completely they could not harm
them in any way whatsoever
therefore they hastened back to the city
to tell mater Kazuma what the strangers
were like and how invulnerable they were
they said to him O Lord we are no match
for them we are mere nothing's Matta
Kazuma at once gave out orders he
commanded the officials and all the
chiefs and captains under the threat of
death to take the utmost pains to learn
what the strangers needed and to provide
it when the spaniards left their ships
and began to march here and were at last
on the way they was served and attended
as they came and great honors were done
them
they marched forward under protection
and everything possible was done to
please them when Mata kazuma heard that
they were inquiring about his person and
when he learned that the gods wish to
see him face to face his heart shrank
within him and he was filled with
anguish he wanted to run away and hide
he thought of evading the gods and
escaping to hide in a cave
he spoke of this to certain trusted
counselors who were not faint-hearted
whose hearts were still firm and
resolute they said there is the place of
the dead the house of the Sun at the
land of tarrlok or the temple of simply
you should go to one or another to
whichever you prefer
mata Kazuma knew what he desired to go
to the temple of Sint Lee and his desire
was made known it was revealed to the
people but he could not do it he could
not run away could not go into hiding he
had lost his strength and his spirit and
could do nothing therefore he did
nothing but wait he did nothing but
resign himself and wait for them to come
he mastered his heart at last and waited
for whatever was to happen